okay it's 2018 we are just a couple of
weeks from the one-year anniversary of
Donald Trump being President of the
United States that's a quarter of his
term almost and now he's been in office
long enough that we can start making
some broader assessments of what's
happened so far and I feel so conflicted
about the one-year mark because on the
one hand I can't believe it's been a
year right it's flown by feels like we
just had the election right but on the
other hand I'm so fatigued by the
constant scandals and embarrassment that
it kind of feels like it's been eight
years I feel like so much has happened
though I've been a lot longer so three
areas that I want to talk about bills
passed how much legislation has Donald
Trump accomplished his approval rating
how is he doing in the opinion of the
public and golf trips not because
golfing is important but because during
the presidency of Barack Obama Donald
Trump was very focused on how much
President Obama was golfing and how much
he would not be golfing if he were ever
president of the United States so let's
talk first about legislation Donald
Trump says he claims he asserts that he
has signed more legislation into law
than any other president during their
first year the truth happens to be the
exact opposite of that
the nonpartisan gov't rack Us website
says that Donald Trump has signed the
fewest bills into law of any recent
recent president dating all the way back
to Eisenhower okay
numerous media outlets tried to get
clarification from the White House Trump
says he has the most bills evidence and
records say the fewest bills how do you
explain that no answer from the White
House so far that's legislation
how about approval rating at the end of
his first year Donald Trump's approval
rating is the lowest of any president
during the modern polling era and we
actually have a list here and you'll see
that George W Bush at the end of his
first year was polling 86% a JFK 77%
Bush 171 % eisenhower 69 Nixon 59 Carter
57 Obama 54 Clinton 54 Reagan 49 and
Donald Trump most recently according to
a CNN poll the same CNN poll
35% not too good but hey the polls are
all fake news so it's not real
and lastly golfing during Obama's
presidency Donald Trump slammed
President Obama for golfing too much
during his campaign Donald Trump said he
wouldn't have any time for golfing he
wouldn't be leaving the White House very
much and yet Donald Trump has golfed 88
times so far at a taxpayer cost of more
than 42 million dollars and compared to
other presidents Trump has golfed more
than any modern president as far as the
golf itself goes yeah it's a huge
disrespect to the taxpayer since this is
all happening with taxpayer money at
Trump's own golf courses funneling
millions of dollars into his own
family's businesses but in a sense Trump
golfing means he's not legislating which
is arguably a good thing but still the
taxpayer money going directly into
Trump's family businesses it's
unacceptable there will probably never
be consequences for Trump for funneling
these millions of dollars into his
businesses through golfing I'm just
being realistic but it's an absolute and
total disrespect to the taxpayer they're
really funny or sad thing and in this
presidency the line between funny and
sad has become pretty blurred in ways I
never before thought possible the funny
or sad thing is that Trump thinks he's
working hard right and his core base
actually believes it over the vacation I
watched very little news and paid
attention to very few things but when I
was on vacation I saw these interviews I
think it was CNN did it with indepe
Trump territory and it also happened to
be a pretty poor part of the country I
don't know if it was rural Florida or
Mississippi or something it was just
total cognitive dissonance right people
were asked how do you think Trump's
doing oh he's just working so hard for
us really for you are you happy with the
tax plan some of these voters were asked
and they said yeah we really are and
then they were asked well hold on isn't
Trump's tax plan mostly for the rich and
the respondents actually said completely
unstart a Stickley with absolutely no
hint of satire or or or understanding of
the reality the tax breaks for the rich
makes sense
poor people don't create jobs rich
people create jobs so it's good that the
rich are getting the taxes they're gonna
create jobs for people like us
total cognitive dissidence I mean they
can explain away anything I mean they'd
actually probably be happy with him
signing fewer bills than any modern
president right because they think that
the government that governs least is the
government that governs best right
that's why either way they're gonna
support what he does right if Trump says
executive orders and tons of legislative
accomplishments they support the
president enacting his agenda if he does
nothing they support a president who
adheres to small government principles
of not doing too much people the
approval ratings and the golfing are a
lot harder for them to respond to it
true and maybe they can point to a
Rasmussen poll that hasn't been 47% yeah
but the golf hypocrisy there's just no
comeback to that we cannot reach these
folks is the conclusion I've come to
everything we know about cognitive
psychology and behavioral economics
about cognitive dissonance tells us that
these are people that we are not going
to reach effectively in a way that might
actually swing an election which gets me
back to something I've been saying for a
year at this point and I even said in
the first story on today's program the
first show back in 2018 and in the
context of the midterms we need to focus
on getting out the vote because voter
turnout is so low you're not going to
convince these folks and by voter
turnout alone we can actually win in
2018 if we're willing to do the work
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show we are back yes it is a new
show no more vacation shows no more
repeats we've dragged back Pat back into
the studio and we are doing a show we'll
take a break and be back after this I'm
pleased to tell you that support for
today's program comes in part from
health IQ health IQ believes that the
best way to improve the health of the
entire world is to celebrate the health
conscious through social and financial
rewards and what health IQ does you know
how if you have well with some car
insurance companies if you're a good
driver you get a discount off of car
insurance it's the same idea with health
IQ and life insurance more than half of
health IQ customers save between four
and thirty three percent on their life
insurance because of the healthy
lifestyles that they live and the reason
that they're able to do this is that
physically active people have a 34%
lower risk of all-cause mortality and a
56% lower risk of heart disease to see
if you qualify get a free quote at
health iq.com
slash Pakman you can also mention the
promo code Pakman if you decide to call
in and speak to a health IQ agent check
it out that is health IQ comm slash PA k
ma n to get your free quote